[Music]
an awesome thing happens every January
where a bunch of crazy talented gamers
get together and play a whole bunch of
different games really fast and raise a
lot of money in the process
it's called awesome games done quick and
it goes for an entire week but here are
five of the most epic speedruns from
this year's marathon first up on my list
is Super Monkey Ball deluxe which also
happens to be my favorite game to watch
in speedrun form that's partly because
it reminds me of when me and my friend
Ali used to spend every eighth grade
technology class playing hamster ball
and partly because this game demands
some serious skill Civil Monkey Ball is
a game you can't win without speed and
dexterity so seeing that escalated with
speedrunning is very cool Jeff that's
his real name and his handle was the
entertaining dude who took on the action
puzzle game slash Peter nightmare in
ultimate mode the difficult levels
include one where Jeff had to gather
enough momentum to pass through
electronic doors which were open for
only point three of a second watching
the small primate plummet in his plastic
bubble and roll through enormous goals
is as wildly addictive to watch as it is
to play particularly while you're
supposed to be in class if you like a
little more competition in your
speedruns you should definitely check
out the ninja gaiden relay race two
teams simultaneously played ninja gaiden
one two and three swapping out players
for each game the three game run only
goes for 40 minutes
and the race is nail-biting ly close the
entire time the infamously difficult
platformer demands pretty precise
movements and strategies and for six
players participating really do seem to
have it down this is a must watch to see
the talent of these people and the fact
that the finale comes down to just two
seconds between the competing teams also
the commentary is really helpful and
insightful if you have no freaking idea
what's going on I want to be the guy is
a game known for its difficulty I want
to be the boshy is an even more
difficult to remake made because
somebody thought the original game was
- easy this runner is playing the last
game on hard while attempting to
complete a 100% speed run this run is
epic not just because the streamer
witwix team rolls through all the stages
where most of us would have a hard time
getting through one but because he's so
damn entertaining to casually chatting
the whole way through while totally
smashing a famously brutal game at
breakneck speeds this Runner is all
kinds of awesome not to mention it's
probably the early opportunity I have to
see the end of this game The Legend of
Zelda Ocarina of Time isn't I want to be
the boshy hot but it certainly would be
difficult to play a blindfolded a feat
this next runner attempted through the
first three dungeon it's seriously cool
to see how much the runner run a guy
2489 knows about where he is in the game
just by listening to the surprisingly
detailed and varied sounds of ocarina of
time it's also fascinating to hear run a
guy tell the story about how he helped a
blind friend play a tape and decided in
the process to figure out how to play it
without the use of sight not only does
he successfully navigate the three
dungeons runnerguy is also able to
successfully execute a bunch of
difficult to activate glitches which
requires specific and frame-perfect
moves all while blindfolded this run is
madness awesome or inspiring madness
finally and this one is probably popped
up on your radar already since it's
sitting at half a million views on
YouTube is Kevin Delia's tetris the
grand master run playing on tgm3 master
mode where the speed and difficulty is
drastically increased runner Kevin DDR
plays the classic puzzle games so well
you feel ashamed to even consider trying
your amateur hand at it well maybe
that's just me although the ridiculously
speedy run culminating in level 999 is
phenomenal in and of itself the best bit
actually occurs during the credits of
the game here Kevin DDR flexes his
tetris skills by successfully planting
blocks on an invisible game board where
he can't see what he's doing it really
needs to be
seen to properly appreciate how
ridiculously clever this speedrunner is
let me know down in the comments which
of these runs was your favorite or if it
was a whole other run entirely for the
full runs you can head to the games done
quick YouTube or twitch page and
congrats to them for raising over one
and a half million dollars for charity I
will see you next week